so few people have figured out how to
play this Matrix of attention properly
as we sit here today the following
platforms are completely underpriced in
both their organic reach and their paid
media Facebook Twitter Snapchat
Instagram Tick Tock YouTube LinkedIn
this is profound all of the platforms
are underpriced why this is so important
a lot of you including myself grew up in
Era where you would amass followers and
you would post and you would get a
percentage of those followers to see it
it was more email marketing than it was
social we are now in the post tick tock
application of social media where you
can absolutely get way more exposure
than you've earned because you don't
have to build a list or a community you
just have to make individual pieces of
content strong this is now penetrated
every platform